hey  awesome  [Music]  i'm not against i know that we've got to  have competitions elsewhere around the  world  i think it's absolutely ridiculous it's  got really found the players the last  thing i want is for our momentum to be  broken  [Music]  i was not angry at all before i came in  but when when we start talking about it  i really get angry everybody knows it's  not right this world cup happens in the  wrong moment  for the wrong reasons it will be a huge  impact emotionally and and physically on  the guys who go to world cup so they  will come back drained physically  drained but also mentally  like with big success with big emotions  positive emotions or huge  disappointments  [Music]  it's a quick turnaround from the last  premiership game on the sunday to when  we play our first game on the monday  so we won't need to  to top them up with regards to training  sessions and look at what minutes  they've played that's that's the biggest  difference for us  [Music]  you